[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what up guys my name is the Cherno
and welcome to a bit of an update video
slash vlog something I haven't done in a
bit of a while but I thought that it
would be worthwhile me updating you that
was going to be happening with the video
scheduling in the next week because
there might be a bit of an interruption
because I'm going to GDC in San
Francisco from the 17th to the 23rd of
March well I'll be leaving on 17 June
you see I think starts on the 19th
but anyway so ei have been nice not to
fly me out to GDC this year as well as
like a few other people from my team so
that's pretty exciting never been to the
US before so never been to DC or
anything like that so I'm really looking
forward to it
Judy say for those of you who don't know
is stands with Game Developers
Conference is basically like one of the
biggest game conferences in the world
I thought it's gonna be like 20,000 plus
people there I think there are a few
really really interesting talks that I'm
looking forward to going to I'm not
presenting or anything like that just
attending if any of you guys going to be
there they'll definitely see you there
and I'm just gonna be hanging around San
Francisco like all week and weekend as
well so that should be pretty exciting
but because of that I'm probably not
gonna be able to do any videos I am
still gonna try and do vlogs and videos
that kind of involve me just talking to
the camera like I am right now I
probably won't be doing any videos that
involve me like programming on my laptop
like the normal sleepless Blasio's open
gels series ones but if there are any
kind of theory videos that I really
should get through that don't really
that don't really require me to write
code in front of you but more or less
just kind of need me to explain
something to the camera
maybe I'm gonna try it see if I can do
some of those and maybe just some
general vlogs that JDC as well so we're
gonna see how that works out but no
promises anyway I thought I'd answer a
few questions so I just tweeted out like
five minutes ago if you guys have any
questions for me so let's just go ahead
and look at the Twitter and answer some
quick questions sir how do you approach
learning an API well when you're
learning an API or you're like learning
how to use a library or something like
that
usually the reason you've like gotten
that library is to saved
development time right because you don't
want to be recreating everything from
scratch so you using a library to kind
of speed that up for you so whilst I
would say that the best thing you can do
is really read all the documentation if
you're talking about like speed and you
want to quickly just get started with an
API usually any good libraries will
include a lot of samples or examples so
you want to take a look at them and see
how you can quickly copy and paste code
and adapt it into your project for what
it is that you're doing specifically
sometimes you won't be able to sometimes
you may need to change things or look at
the documentation or maybe just tinker
around with the code a bit but I would
say just if you're looking for the
easiest way look at the actual samples
that they provide all the example
projects that they provide larger
libraries should have a bunch for each
kind of like major feature they support
so definitely check that out and see if
if you can just basically copy and paste
some code from the examples into your
project off the library and get
something running as quickly as possible
and then from them then you can kind of
work on iterating it and getting better
and improving it for your actual use
case do you plan on doing tutorial
videos on other programming languages
after you're done with C++ if so what
would be the next one so professionally
I really just use C++ and C sharp most
of all I really really likes his sharp I
still thinks a boss boss is probably my
favorite programming language but C
sharp is definitely a very close second
I'm not sure if I would ever do c-sharp
tutorials maybe in the future I'm
thinking like for the game engine series
there may be situations in which I
decide to write some tools for that in
c-sharp so that like potentially I might
want to use a c-sharp for that and maybe
I'll end up doing a few such I'm not
sure to be honest I'm not sure what's
gonna happen with that but when the game
engine Siri is speaking of the game
engine series by the way just so you
guys know the exact airing of the first
episode for that series is going to be
on I got you there to be honest I've
I've got an idea it's gonna come when it
when it comes because I'm still planning
and working on it
but anyway moving on so I'm currently at
college studying computer science what
extracurricular activities special
project should I focus on to be more
attracted to companies in the future
that's pretty good question
really hard to answer it really depends
on the company that you're applying to
if you know that you're applying to a
company that is like a triple a game
studio that uses and their own engine
that they've written in C++ and maybe
you know mostly they use C++ for game
programming and maybe like a bit of
lower for scripting or Python for
scripting or seizure whatever it is that
they use try and demonstrate that you're
capable of using those technologies that
specific kind of development stack right
so showed that you can make your own
engine in C++ and you can make a game
using c-sharp with that surplus lost
engine or whatever have that unlike
github like as a portfolio like on a
website or something like that sure that
you can actually use the tools that
they're using that's gonna be by far the
best thing that you can do it for
example I was really interested in game
engines I made my own game engines when
I applied for a job they saw that and
they hired me onto the game engine team
because obviously I was really
passionate about that and that's what I
enjoyed doing nice I definitely think
about that if you're applying for a team
that uses unity then build the game in
unity maybe similar to the one that
they're working on obviously you've
probably be much smaller scale but sure
that you can function like them and that
you would fit well into their team
that's gonna be really important but
obviously like programming and all that
kind of skill and ability isn't the only
thing that matters when you're looking
for a job like a software company or a
game studio you also have to be like a
person that the team would enjoy having
on their team so definitely think about
like how you read how you work in a team
setting and bring up some nice examples
that would make that team think that you
would be a good fit for them because
ultimately like what I look for in a
person is not someone who is really
really smart but likes to work alone and
isn't a team player I'd much rather have
someone who is just more passionate
about doing what they're doing doesn't
mind being corrected doesn't mind
admitting that they're wrong in
situations because we're all wrong like
all the time it happens we're human
I would much rather a person like that
there was a little bit like not as smart
or doesn't know as much as someone who
is but he's not a pleasure to work with
that's very very important anyway that's
gonna wrap up this video hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did even hit the like
button obviously you can leave a comment
with any other questions you might you
might have I might get to that in a
future video maybe I'll film some vlogs
on the plane more answers and questions
or something like that I've got a bunch
of topics that I wanted to get through
as well I'll try my best to do them in
them maybe the coming weeks would be
probably a good chance to just pull out
the camera and do a bit of the vlog but
anyway I will see you guys maybe in San
Francisco but otherwise good bye
[Music]
[Music]